Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Uno dei miei sogni, quando ero bambino,
era quello di diventare
pilota di elicottero.
L'idea di stare con le mani,
la testa, il corpo
su un mezzo sospeso in aria,
tra le nuvole,
mi ha sempre affascinato.
In realtà, la vita poi
ti porta a percorrere strade diverse.
Diametralmente opposte,
in alcuni casi come il mio.
Io ho fatto infatti un po'
la fine dello struzzo:
sono finito con la testa sottoterra.
Faccio il biotecnologo del suolo,
ovvero mi occupo di studiare
tutto ciò che vive sotto i nostri piedi,
la biodiversità del suolo,
e per farlo utilizzo
la biologia molecolare,
ovvero lo studio del DNA.
Ma partiamo dal "suolo".
Questo è un termine
che non sentiamo molto spesso
perché per indicarlo si utilizzano
parole diverse come "terra", "terreno".
Inoltre, quando lo sentiamo,
quelle poche volte,
molto spesso ha un'accezione negativa.
Pensiamo a una mamma, o a un papà,
che vedono il loro bambino,
o la loro bambina,
rientrare in casa con le mani,
o i piedi sporchi di terra.
La prima cosa che gli dicono è:
corri a lavarti le mani, pulisciti!
Bene, figuriamoci immaginare qualcuno
che possa studiare il suolo.
Se io mi abbasso, e guardo,
vedo una superficie piatta,
solitamente di colore marrone, inanimata.
Cosa ci sarà mai di tanto interessante,
da studiare lì sotto?
In realtà, il suolo,
se osservato da un'altra prospettiva,
non dall'alto verso il basso
ma da vicino, di profilo,
ci potrà sorprendere.
La prima cosa che emerge agli occhi
è sicuramente il colore.
I suoli non sono solo marroni,
ci sono centinaia di sfumature
di colore del suolo.
Si va dai suoli neri
tipici delle torbiere, ad esempio,
ricchi di sostanza organica,
ai suoli bianchi tipici
delle zone desertiche, ricchi di calcare.
Si passa poi dai suoli ricchi di ferro,
e di colore rosso o giallo,
presenti nelle zone tropicali.
E poi, ovviamente, sì,
c'è il suolo marrone.
Lo troviamo, ad esempio,
nelle foreste e nei pascoli,
soprattutto nelle nostre zone,
alle nostre latitudini.
Forse per questo siamo abituati
a pensare a quel colore lì.
Cambiando il colore,
cambiano le proprietà del suolo.
Cambia il suo PH, il contenuto
di nutrienti, di sostanza organica.
Cambia anche le proprietà,
quali la fertilità.
Ma soprattutto cambia
la componente biologica, la parte viva.
Sì, perché se osserviamo
un suolo da vicino,
il suolo risulta essere
tutt'altro che inanimato.
Un suolo è vivo, è ricco di biodiversità.
Quando parliamo, però,
di biodiversità del suolo,
molto spesso ci vengono in mente
un paio di specie simbolo:
la talpa; il lombrico.
Sì, ci sono, assolutamente, innegabile.
In realtà, la biodiversità del suolo
però è molto di più,
sia in termini di colori,
[che] di forme e di dimensioni.
Si va dal mondo microscopico,
rappresentato da funghi e batteri,
che sono i veri
dominatori numerici del suolo:
in una manciata di suolo possiamo contare
centinaia di migliaia di specie diverse
di questi microrganismi;
fino al mondo macroscopico,
rappresentato, sì, da insetti,
come le formiche o le termiti;
e poi anche piccoli mammiferi,
di cui la talpa è un esempio,
ma sicuramente non l'unico.
E poi c'è tutta la "Terra di Mezzo",
rappresentata da specie meno note
ma non per questo
meno affascinanti e importanti,
come ad esempio acari e isopodi.
Bene, allora, guardando
tutta questa biodiversità,
forse il mio sogno iniziale
di avere la testa fra le nuvole
posso dire che in parte l’ho avverato.
Si dice, infatti, che esistano
più specie sotto i nostri piedi
che stelle in cielo.
E il paragone, credetemi, non è azzardato.
Infatti, un quarto della biodiversità,
sul nostro pianeta,
si trova sotto i nostri piedi,
e di questa una larga parte
è ancora da scoprire.
Solo il cinque percento
dei funghi che potenzialmente esistono
sono stati descritti,
quindi c'è veramente un mondo
da scoprire sotto i nostri piedi.
E per farlo, a differenza
delle galassie e delle stelle,
che si trovano a distanze impercorribili,
è sufficiente abbassarsi
e raccogliere pochi grammi di suolo,
per poi iniziare a studiarlo.
Come studiare, però,
la biodiversità del suolo?
Qui la tecnologia, negli ultimi anni,
sicuramente ci ha dato una grossa mano.
Esiste infatti un elemento
che accomuna tutte le specie,
ma al tempo stesso le rende uniche:
sto parlando del DNA.
Grazie alla tecnologia
oggi è possibile, di fatto,
sequenziare il DNA di qualunque organismo,
dal più piccolo batterio
al più grande albero.
Ma non solo: è possibile, anche,
sequenziare il DNA di un ambiente,
di qualunque ambiente.
E quando dico qualunque,
intendo davvero tutti.
Si va dal nostro intestino,
pensiamo a tutti gli studi
sul microbioma intestinale,
a una goccia d'acqua,
a un grammo di suolo.
E il DNA ambientale,
che è studiato da una scienza
che prende il nome di genomica ambientale,
o metagenomica,
è rappresentato dalla somma dei DNA
degli organismi che vivono
in quell’ambiente.
Se io quindi vado a leggere
il DNA di un ambiente,
andrò a caratterizzare
la sua biodiversità.
Bene, allora sappiamo
che sotto i nostri piedi c'è tanta vita
e ci sono dei modi per studiarla.
Ma una domanda potrebbe essere:
A me cosa interessa sapere
che in quel determinato suolo
vive quel gruppo di funghi o di termiti?
Bè, la risposta è abbastanza semplice:
perché la biodiversità del suolo è utile!
Ci sono sempre più studi che dimostrano
come i servizi offerti al genere umano
dalla biodiversità del suolo
siano molteplici.
Io vi farò tre esempi.
Il primo, il cibo.
Pensiamo alla frutta e alla verdura
che troviamo tutti i giorni
nei nostri scaffali del supermercato.
Bene, se è lì dobbiamo dire grazie
anche a dei microrganismi del suolo.
Ci sono, infatti, dei funghi
che vivono in simbiosi
con le radici delle piante,
che avvolgono in una fitta tela
e aiutano la pianta ad estrarre
i nutrienti e l'acqua dal suolo.
In questo modo, la pianta cresce meglio
e con lei i suoi frutti,
che poi arrivano sulle nostre tavole.
Quindi, la biodiversità del suolo
ci aiuta nella produzione del cibo.
Secondo, gli antibiotici.
Uno dei problemi "caldi",
in questo momento, per la medicina
è la ricerca di nuovi antibiotici.
Perché quelli che conosciamo
sono sempre meno,
li usiamo troppo,
sono poco efficaci, quindi.
Pensate allora a tutti gli organismi
che vivono nel suolo.
Per sopravvivere devono, letteralmente,
combattere tra di loro, uccidersi, quindi.
E per farlo producono molecole
antimicrobiche, antibatteriche.
Ecco, allora, che il suolo
potrebbe essere una fonte
inesauribile di antibiotici.
E questo non ci sorprende
perché, di fatto,
già gli antibiotici
che stiamo utilizzando,
come ad esempio la streptomicina
che è prodotta da un batterio
che forma delle colonie
che ricordano un po'
la muffa sulla marmellata,
arrivano proprio dal suolo.
Ecco allora che la biodiversità del suolo
ci aiuta anche nella ricerca biomedica.
Terzo, il cambiamento climatico.
I periodi di siccità
stanno aumentando sempre di più,
e con essi la sofferenza
di ecosistemi, come le foreste,
dove le piccole piante,
in carenza di acqua, semplicemente,
non sono in grado di sopravvivere.
Si è visto che in presenza di un gruppo
di organismi del suolo, le termiti,
che, come le api e le formiche,
vivono in una struttura a casta,
con una regina
e con delle operaie e dei soldati
al suo completo servizio,
ebbene, si è visto
che in presenza di questi insetti
l’ambiente, l'ecosistema è in grado
di reagire molto meglio alla siccità.
Questo perché il suolo rimane più umido,
la decomposizione più alta
e quindi le piantine sono in grado
di sopravvivere facilmente
ai periodi di siccità.
Ecco, allora, che possiamo dire
che la biodiversità del suolo
ci aiuta anche a combattere
gli effetti negativi
del cambiamento climatico.
Ma lasciatemi fare un passo in più.
Quando pensiamo alla protezione
della biodiversità,
in generale, pensiamo
a delle specie simbolo,
come ad esempio il panda.
A tutti piace il panda: è una specie
che trasmette tenerezza, è bello.
Be', lasciatemelo dire,
anche la biodiversità
del suolo, se conosciuta,
ci potrà sorprendere
da questo punto di vista.
È bella, presenta delle varietà di colori
che non hanno nulla da invidiare
con quella delle piante.
Oppure una tenerezza e un candore
che non hanno nulla da invidiare
rispetto a dei cuccioli di animali.
Anche per questo penso
che la biodiversità del suolo
vada conosciuta e protetta.
La necessità di proteggere
la biodiversità del suolo
è dovuta al fatto
che è sempre più minacciata.
Non solo da minacce che sono tipiche,
anche, della biodiversità sopra il suolo,
come ad esempio la deforestazione
o il cambiamento climatico;
ma ci sono anche minacce tipiche
del suolo, della sua biodiversità.
Un esempio è l'erosione,
ovvero la perdita di suolo
a causa di eventi molto intensi,
di piogge molto intense.
In Europa si stima
che ogni anno vengono perse
900 milioni di tonnellate di suolo
a causa di fenomeni di questo tipo.
E con essa perdiamo anche la biodiversità.
Allora il fenomeno,
così intenso, così preoccupante,
ci deve portare a muoverci, ad agire.
E questo è quello che facciamo
al Centro Comune di Ricerca.
Proviamo a mappare la biodiversità,
perché per proteggere qualcosa
il primo passo è capire
dove quel qualcosa si trova.
Così nel 2016 abbiamo pubblicato
la prima mappa globale
della biodiversità del suolo.
Come vedete, in Europa
non c'è così tanta ricchezza di suolo,
soprattutto se la paragoniamo
ad aree come l'Amazzonia,
piuttosto che l’Africa equatoriale.
Tuttavia, è necessaria la mappatura
perché la biodiversità del suolo,
essendo complessa,
è molto difficile da mappare.
La mappa, infatti, che abbiamo fatto
è tutt'altro che completa:
è un primo passo, è un inizio.
La metagenomica ci sta aiutando
a cercare di colmare
le lacune e le dimenticanze.
Queste mappe verranno poi utilizzate
per sviluppare delle normative ad hoc
per la protezione
della biodiversità del suolo.
Ma prima della ricerca scientifica,
e dello sviluppo di normative
che consentano la protezione
della biodiversità del suolo,
ci siamo noi, e la vita di ogni giorno.
Noi che dovremmo iniziare
a interessarci, interrogarci,
raccontare, parlare di suolo
e di sua biodiversità.
Dovremmo veramente provare a creare
una cultura del suolo,
che al momento manca.
Dovremmo imparare a conoscere il suolo
e la sua biodiversità.
A non temerlo,
a non vederlo come qualcosa di sporco.
La biodiversità è bella,
la biodiversità è utile.
La biodiversità ci consente, veramente,
di fare molte, molte cose.
Proprio per questo
dobbiamo giocare col suolo,
far giocare i nostri figli col suolo,
sporcarci letteralmente le mani.
Ecco, stasera vi lascio
con un altro sogno.
Mi piacerebbe che una mamma e un papà,
quando vedono il loro bambino
o la loro bambina
entrare in casa con le mani
sporche di terra -
o di suolo, meglio,
in questo caso utilizziamo
il termine giusto,
non gli dicessero,
corri a lavarti le mani!
Ma gli chiedessero: ti sei divertito?
Hai trovato qualcosa di interessante?
Raccontamelo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)